There's a statistic that over 90% of
people go home at the end of the day
feeling unfulfilled by their work.
This is the difference between liking
your job and loving your job.
You can like your job,
but do you love your job?
And over 90% of the people who,
who work these days don't.
Um,
and I imagine a world in which that
statistic is completely reversed in
which the vast majority of people go
home at the end of the day feeling
fulfilled by the work that they do,
feeling that they've contributed to
something bigger than the bigger than
themselves.
I've always been a pretty happy go lucky
guy.
But about five years ago,
I reached a point in my career where my
passion was gone.
Um,
I stopped loving what I was doing and I
even got to the point where I didn't
really like it anymore.
And for a happy person,
just being unhappy,
it was bad enough.
And it was this point in my life that I
made this discovery,
this thing called the why.
And what I learned is that every single
organization on the planet,
even our own careers,
function on three levels.
What we do,
how we do it,
and why we do it.
These are the things that we think make
us different or special compared to
everyone else.
But very few of us can clearly
articulate why we do what we do.
And I don't mean to earn a living or
provide for your family.
It was a results by why.
I mean,
what's your purpose?
What's your cause,
what's your belief?
And after I learned my why,
I literally stopped telling people what
I did and only started telling them what
I believed.
And not only was my passion restored,
but Mike Career and my life changed
dramatically and took on an in an
entirely new path with,
with,
with vastly more meaning.